bonjour à toutes et à tous madame la
Défenseur des droits je vous salue ainsi
que l'ensemble des collaborateurs et de
votre équipe qui vous accompagne
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues donc nous poursuivons ce matin
les travaux de notre commission
d'enquête avec votre audition madame et
donc vous avez été nommé Défenseur des
droits le 22 juillet 2020 vous êtes la
troisième personne à occuper cette
fonction après Dominique bouddhiste et
Jacques Toubon le 14 octobre 2022 vous
avez rendu une décision sur ma prime
rénov qui a eu pour le moins
retentissement important vous faisiez le
constat de dysfonctionnement aux
conséquences lourdes pour les usagers et
vous formuliez plusieurs recommandations
pour y remédier ainsi vous aviez relevé
qu'un nombre de dossiers pour lesquels
vous avez été directement saisi
connaissez des difficultés d'ordre
technique les demandeurs ne parvenez pas
enregistrer leur demande d'autres n'ont
pas réussi à téléverser leurs pièces
justificatives et enfin certains n'ont
pas pu modifier leur dossier qui
comprenaient des informations
erronées et qui a donc conduit à leur
annulation tous ces dysfonctionnements
ont amené à ce que des personnes n'ont
pas pu réaliser les travaux avant
l'hiver ou alors à ce qu'elles n'ont pas
pu faire financer les travaux réalisés
ce qui a malheureusement augmenté l'état
de précarité financière dans lesquelles
ce ménage ce ménage appartenant bien sûr
souvent aux catégories de revenus les
plus modestes voire très modeste se
trouver déjà en conséquence vous
préconisez de résoudre au plus vite les
difficultés techniques de permettre aux
usagers de modifier leur dossier et de
régulariser les dossiers qui n'auraient
pas abouti en raison des
dysfonctionnements
durant son audition la direction
générale de Lana a indiqué que la moitié
des dossiers problématiques avaient déjà
été réglé au moment où vous aviez rendu
votre décision quel est donc Madame la
Défenseur des droits la situation
aujourd'hui est-ce que des dossiers
continuent à poser des difficultés nous
sommes quand même être le cas serait-ce
que quand on écoute un certain nombre de
nos collègues qui nous font remonter des
dysfonctionnements encore venant de
territoire
Lana a-t-elle suivi vos recommandations
dans votre décision vous mettiez
également l'accent sur le défaut
d'information des personnes qui
effectuent les démarches et l'absence
d'interlocuteurs lorsqu'elle rencontre
des difficultés vous avez qualifié les
motivations de refus d'octroyer une aide
ou de diminution du montant versé de
succincte voire confuse enfin vous
financiers l'absence de solution
alternative à la procédure
dématérialisée alors que la possibilité
d'entamer et de poursuivre des démarches
de manière physique est un droit qui est
consacré par la jurisprudence
administrative ce point a-t-il été
corrigé avant de vous laisser la parole
pour répondre à ses premières questions
et pour un propos introductif d'environ
une quinzaine de minutes il me revient
de vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'un compte
rendu sera publié je dois également vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête serait
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100.000 euros d'amende
je vous invite donc Madame la Défenseur
des droits a prêté serment de dire toute
la vérité rien que la vérité a levé la
main droite et à dire je le jure
je vous en remercie donc je vous
souhaite bien volontiers la parole et
puis ensuite à la fois notre rapporteur
et nos collègues qui sont présents aussi
à cette audition ne manquerons pas très
certainement de vous poser d'autres
questions c'est à vous merci
faut que je mette le micro pour ceux qui
sont à distance madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames les
sénatrices et messieurs les sénateurs
d'abord je vous remercie vraiment pour
votre invitation vous savez que la
question de l'accès au droit de l'accès
au service public est vraiment au cœur
des missions de notre institution du
Défenseur des droits et je redis
autorité administrative indépendante
dans l'existence a été consacrée dans la
Constitution juste un chiffre pour
démarrer au cours de l'année 2022 nous
avons reçu 126 000 réclamations nous
allons d'ailleurs sortir notre rapport
annuel en début de semaine prochaine où
nous détaillerons tous ces chiffres et
là-dessus 90 000 concernés la relation
avec les services publics et justement
ces difficultés d'éloignement des
services publics et je sais que c'est
quelque chose qui qui vous préoccupe
justement particulièrement au Sénat et
donc se motif de saisine relève d'une de
nos cinq compétences et qui est donc de
loin le premier motif de de réclamation
que nous recevons et dans ces
réclamations de façon assez générale
elle témoigne d'un manquement dans le
fonctionnement des services publics il y
a une forme de déshumanisation de
l'administration d'éloignement lié à la
dématérialisation dont je dirais
toujours à la stérilisation peut-être
une chance mais peut aussi éloigner des
services publics votre commission
d'enquête elle s'intéresse en
particulier aux politiques publiques en
matière de rénovation énergétique et
vous le savez donc on a eu à travailler
dans ce cadre-là sur ma prime rénov et
on se doute bien de ce qui peut aussi se
passer après je pense que c'est d'où
l'intérêt aussi de la commission
d'enquête que que vous menez nous avons
et vous l'avez dit reçu 500 réclamations
au moment où nous avons rendu cette
décision au mois d'octobre depuis 900
nouvelles réclamations sont arrivées
donc ce qui prouve bien que quand on
médiatise un sujet les personnes qui
sont concernées par ce problème
n'avaient pas idée qu'elle pouvait nous
saisir ont eu idée sur les 900
réclamations supplémentaires 600 n'ont
toujours pas reçu de réponse
et je ne partage pas tout à fait
l'optimisme des 500 réclamations au
moment où on sort notre décision dans la
moitié serait réglé parce qu'en fait on
a aussi été alerté par des réclamants
qui effectivement avait reçu un courrier
mais ça ne voulait pas dire que le
problème était réglé si j'avais reçu une
partie de réponse mais le problème
n'était pas réglé et en fait il nous
ressaisissent dans ces cas-là parce que
nous on voilà on considère appartement
là que c'était Chloé ça ne l'était pas
il y a trois points que je voudrais vous
préciser dans ce propos introductif
d'abord le contenu des réclamations
vous présentez de façon un peu plus
détaille les recommandations que nous
avons fait et effectivement quels sont
celles qui ont été suivies et pas
suivies si vous voulez bien je vais
commencer par un exemple pour illustrer
mon propos c'est celle d'une femme âgée
qui devait changer sa chaudière et pour
cela elle pouvait bénéficier de ma prime
rénov elle a donc créé un compte sur le
site de Lana et malgré plusieurs
tentatives elle n'est pas parvenue à
compléter son dossier et entre temps sa
chaudière a cessé de fonctionner et elle
s'est donc retrouvée privé à la fois
d'eau chaude et de et de chauffage en
plein hiver elle s'est donc résolue à
procéder aux travaux avant la réponse de
la NAS qui en principe a pour
conséquence de la priver du bénéfice de
la prime rénove et on efface à le cas
d'une femme âgée qui se trouve privé de
l'aide financière auquel elle a droit en
fait en raison d'un dysfonctionnement
technique de la plateforme dans une
procédure intégralement des matérialisée
elle a saisi le Défenseur des droits et
on a pu démêler et elle a pu avoir le
versement de l'aide au final mais mais
voilà à quoi sert nos interventions on y
arrive sur une partie mais je vous le
redirai sur une partie on y arrive pas à
résoudre les problèmes de manière
générale les problèmes techniques
affectant la plateforme le défaut
d'information vous l'avez vous l'avez
dit les délais de traitements les
difficultés liées à la dématérialisation
totale de la procédure sont autant
d'obstacles que nos concitoyens
subissaient subissent encore et qui
peuvent conduire les usagers les plus
précaires à se retrouver dans une
situation difficile parce que cette
prime rénove elle a quand même été mise
en place justement pour les foyers les
plus les plus démunis et ce sont
aujourd'hui encore ces foyers les plus
démunis qui pâtissent des
dysfonctionnements du service du manque
d'interlocuteurs et du défaut
d'information et nous avons constaté de
nombreux écueils dans le traitement tel
que l'impossibilité de créer un compte
ou un dossier de déposer en ligne des
pièces justificatives ou encore de
modifier des éléments du dossier et
finalement d'engager les travaux je vous
rappelle juste que sur le site des
impôts on peut à tout moment modifier
ces déclarations et c'est bien ce qu'il
faut faire aussi dans les dans les
autres démarches et toutes ces entraves
vont entraîner d'importantes
conséquences pour les
usagers
ces blocages précarisent les demandeurs
les plus fragiles économiquesment et
face à la nécessité de se chauffer
l'hiver et en attente du versement de la
prime rénov certains foyers ont été dans
l'obligation de contacter des prêts
bancaires ou des prêts familiaux pour
financer les travaux et payer les
artisans et on parle d'un certain cas
quand même de plusieurs milliers d'euros
pour le traitement de réclamation
individuelle que nous avons reçu nous
avons systématiquement ces îles et
services de Lana si certains dossiers
ont pu aboutir favorablement c'est pas
du tout le cas de tous les difficultés
ont persisté pour un bon nombre d'entre
eux toujours à cause de
dysfonctionnement de la plateforme et de
délai de traitement anormalement élevé
vous l'avez dit en mois d'octobre on en
était à 500 saisies je vous rappelle 900
depuis
le deuxième point que je voulais aborder
avec vous c'était les recommandations
que nous avions fait à ce moment-là
vraiment je le redis et vous l'avez vous
l'avez évoqué dans votre introduction la
réalisation des démarches
administratives des matérialisées doit
demeurer une possibilité ouverte à
l'usager et non une obligation
en aucun cas cela ne doit conduire à
priver certains bénéficiaires potentiels
d'une aide et notre objectif est de
remédier durablement des défaillances
structurelles et donc nous avons fait 5
recommandations à Lana
mettre en place les mesures de nature
définitivement les difficultés
techniques affectant sa plateforme de
dépôt des dossiers de demande d'aide
diminuer les délais de traitement des
dossiers confrontés à des difficultés
améliorer l'information des usagers
notamment par la mise en place
d'interlocuteurs qualifiés voués assurer
un meilleur suivi des dossiers et des
réclamations et la communication dans
les décisions d'éléments d'analyse de
nature à les justifier entre autres
quand il y a eu une baisse du versement
prévu ou un non versement prendre la
tâche de ces ministres de tutelle afin
de mettre en place un canal de dépôt des
demandes en complément de la procédure
des matériels et régurer et régulariser
l'ensemble des demandes d'aide n'ayant
pu aboutir en raison de difficultés
imputables à la mise en oeuvre du
dispositif tels que des difficultés des
dysfonctionnements techniques rencontrés
sur la plateforme les délais de
traitement des dossiers ou l'absence de
prise en compte des avis de dégrèvement
les impôts
alors quelles ont été les évolutions et
les suites données assez recommandations
alors Lana a bien répondu à cette
décision par un courrier en date du 10
janvier 2023 il nous a fait part de ses
observations des améliorations dans la
gestion des dossiers ont indéniablement
été constatés notamment avec la mise en
place d'un service dédié à la relation
avec les usagers mais les usagers
rencontrent encore de nombreux problèmes
dans le traitement de leur dossier et le
Défenseur des droits continue d'être
régulièrement ces isges vous les dit 900
saisines supplémentaires ce qui fait
quand même si on ajoute au 500400 et
nous continuons le suivi des dossiers
individuels sur lequel nous avons saisi
l'ANA qui systématiquement insaisie et
qui n'ont toujours pas abouti les délais
de traitement de la NAS sont très longs
pour certains dossiers et certains
dossiers peinent à être résolus malgré
les relances régulières de mes services
et par ailleurs de nouvelles difficultés
nous ont été remontées pour les
entrepreneurs remplissant le rôle de
mandataire financier et sur qui pèse les
financière lié à l'absence de versement
de l'aide et qui met en difficulté de
petites entreprises et de petits
entrepreneurs nous sommes toujours
pleinement mobilisés sur les dossiers ma
prime rénov et nous assurons en
parallèle le suivi de la décision du
mois d'octobre je voudrais revenir sur
les différents sujets sur lequel nous
avons fait des recommandations sur la
quantité de dossiers rencontrant des
difficultés Lana indique que si des
anomalies erreurs ou lacunes ont été
constatées elles restent dans des
proportions sans commune mesure avec les
volumes de décision d'octroi de la prime
et de paiement délivrée chaque jour par
l'agence bien évidemment nous ne voyons
nous et je le redis à chaque fois dans
l'institution du défenseur droit que ce
qui ne va pas nous sommes un bon
observatoire de ce qui ne va pas mais
nous ne voyons que ce qui ne va pas par
rapport aux saisies et de toutes les
manières tout dysfonctionnement qui est
à engendre une atteinte au droit ne peut
être trop lérée d'ailleurs quelle que
soit le nombre d'usagers concernés et je
continue à dire que nous sommes une
institution pas forcément bien connue du
grand public donc nous n'ayant qu'une
partie des dysfonctionnements et c'est
évidemment que l'intégralité des
difficultés ne nous remonte pas et ce
que je pense c'est qu'il faut rétablir
et remédier au plus vite et rétablir les
usagers dans leurs droits sans attendre
sur les dysfonctionnements techniques de
la plateforme alors on a observé une
certaine amélioration de la qualité du
service rendu aux usagers cependant
franchement l'ensemble des difficultés
est loin d'être résolu certains de nos
réclamants dont les dossiers sont en
souffrance depuis longtemps ne
parviennent toujours pas à accéder à
leur compte ou à déposer des pièces et
quant à la prise en compte de la
situation des demandeurs ayant connu une
difficulté à déposer leurs demandes elle
ne permet malheureusement pas de
répondre à l'ensemble des situations il
est désormais prévu que le bénéficiaire
de la prime peut bénéficier dans
certains cas d'un délai supplémentaire
lorsque des circonstances extérieures à
sa volonté on fait obstacle au
commencement ou à l'achèvement des
travaux et prestations mais d'une part
la durée de cette prorogation n'est pas
toujours suffisante pour certains
dossiers confrontés à des difficultés
persistantes et d'autre part cette
prorogation ne répond pas à l'ensemble
des difficultés en ne prenant notamment
pas en compte les cas dans lesquels les
demandeurs n'ont pas pu attendre pour
exécuter l'entièreté des travaux
exemples que je vous ai donné au début
sur l'absence de prise en compte des
avis de dégrèvement fiscal alors Lana
indique que ces services utilisent
depuis le 1er janvier 2023 la pie un pot
particulier de la DG Philippe qui leur
permet de prendre en compte les avis des
dégrèvements des usagers dès le dépôt de
la demande cette évolution permet
l'instruction des demandes d'aide
conformément à la situation fiscale
réelle du potentiel bénéficiaire mais
Lana ne s'est pas engagée à régulariser
les demandes n'ayant pas pu aboutir en
raison de l'absence de prise en compte
des avis de dégrèvement
sur le défaut d'information
afin de faciliter la lecture et la
compréhension des motifs des décisions
par les usagers je cite la NAT un
travail d'amélioration de la
documentation de l'agence est
actuellement menée afin d'accroître la
compréhension des décisions prises
notamment lorsqu'elle relève de rejet ou
de retrait donc ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour autant cette mesure n'est
pas suffisante pour permettre aux
usagers de comprendre spécifiquement et
individuellement les motifs de la
décision qui leur est opposé et de
former le cas échéant un recours
pertinent contre contre celle-ci sur les
c'est quelque chose qu'on voit sur
l'ensemble de l'accès aux services
publics quand c'est assez général de ne
pas expliquer aux réclamants pourquoi
voilà et c'est quelque chose d'important
qui permettrait voilà plus de fluidité
sur les délais de traitement des
réclamations Lana relève que certains
dossiers complexes anciens qui n'ont pas
encore pu être complètement résolus
bénéficie d'un double dispositif
spécifique via un accompagnement à la
fois par téléphone et une détection
proactive et sur ce point nous avons
bien constaté que certains
usagers ont confirmé avoir été contactés
par Lana mais ce n'est pas du tout le
cas pour tous les usagers et nos
délégués continuent ainsi de déplorer
l'absence d'interlocuteurs clairement
identifié facilement joignable pour
fluidifier les échanges et améliorer le
traitement de leurs demandes enfin sur
l'absence de procédure alternatives à la
dématérialisation de la demande vous le
savez n'a pas souhaité mettre en place
un canal alternatif de dépôt des
demandes en complément de la procédure
dématérialisée je le regrette compte
tenu des dysfonctionnements persistants
et de façon plus générale d'ailleurs les
dysfonctionnements informatiques et les
bugs informatiques existeront toujours
et il faudra toujours pouvoir joindre
quelqu'un et ça aussi on peut le dire
sur l'ensemble des démarches avec les
services publics plusieurs dispositifs
d'accompagnement des usagers sont en
cours de mise en place notamment avec la
possibilité de recourir à un mandataire
qui peut être un proche un conseiller
France rénov ou un Artis mais ces
dispositifs sont insuffisants pour
plusieurs raisons en premier lieu la
création du compte demeure une
prérogative du demandeur de l'aide et
les difficultés intrinsèques il y a
toute procédure dématérialisée
nécessitant d'accéder à du matériel
informatique à une connexion Internet à
une compétence particulière reste donc
entière en second lieu de nombreux
artisans remplissant le rôle de
mandataire financier pour leurs clients
nous ont fait remonter des difficultés
qu'il rencontre il pointe notamment du
doigt le fait que Lana entre directement
en contact avec les clients et qui leur
est dès lors impossible de savoir ce qui
leur a été demandé et certains clients
très âgés ont créé une adresse mail
uniquement pour créer leur compte mais
n'utilise pas en réalité cette adresse
les mandataires relèvent également que
en qualité de mandataire financier ils
ont avancé le montant des frais
correspondant aux aides de Lana à leurs
clients mais les versements se faisant
tarder leur activité est mise en péril
cette situation particulièrement
préjudiciable pour les artisans ayant
endossé le rôle de mandataire financier
nécessite que la nappe prenne des
mesures de nature à remédier au plus
vite à ces difficultés voilà les
observations que je souhaitais vous
faire en introduction mais de manière
générale je vous rappelais qu'il ne peut
y avoir de transformation numérique sans
garantir réellement l'accès au service
public et par la même l'accès aux droits
et derrière cette question est posée la
question de l'égalité des droits les
services publics incarnés droits ils ont
pour mission de les rendre concrets et
accessibles et lorsque ce rôle n'est pas
assuré cela signifie que des personnes
sont laissées de côté sont exclus la
distance des services publics signifie
le recul des droits qui accentue les
vulnérabilités et la cohésion sociale
merci merci beaucoup pour cette exposé
préliminaire déjà très complet donc
monsieur le rapporteur ne m'a pas manqué
de vous poser d'autres questions merci
merci madame la Présidente la Défenseur
des droits déjà pour votre exposé oui
très très complet et qui qui révèle bien
à la fois à travers nos auditions à
travers les remontées qu'on peut avoir
chacun dans nos dans nos territoires et
les sollicitations qu'on peut avoir
aussi également sur les les utilisateurs
de ma prime rénove et toutes ces
problématiques là et c'est vrai qu'ils
mine de rien ne sont pas enfin des
conséquences souvent souvent dramatiques
parce que c'est vrai que vous donniez
l'exemple de la
de la vieille dame mais moi j'ai plein
de cas où des personnes qui de bonne foi
ont engagé tout un processus et ils sont
partis changement de chaudière ou autre
en estimant que ils allaient toucher
leur prime puis en fait pour des petites
erreurs en fait matérielles au départ
mais la touche pas et donc avec des
conséquences financières qui sont qui
sont très très difficile par la suite
donc en fait moi il y avait déjà une
première question c'était peut-être sur
justement cette question du droit à
l'erreur parce que moi j'ai pu voir
c'est l'énorme difficulté en fait pour
parfois vraiment pas grand chose j'ai un
cas sur
un problème de date du devis qui a pas
été enfin il fallait que ça soit de vie
après ou avant enfin en tout cas qui est
pas rentré dans le
quasi l'impossibilité de revenir en
arrière quoi et même à casse-tête enfin
voilà on se demande comment y arriver
donc ça je pense faire est-ce que vous
avez déjà fait des préconisations
justement sur ce sur ce droit à l'erreur
parce que c'est vrai que ça existe sur
d'autres
nos aspects de pouvoir dire un moment
donné oui je me suis trompé et de bonne
foi parce que c'est vrai qu'en plus je
trouve que sur l'ensemble des exemples
qu'on peut avoir on peut quasi dire que
c'est pas des fraudes derrière quoi
c'est vraiment des choses de bonne foi
et des gens qui sont oui parfois
peut-être pas assez renseigné mais en
tout cas donc en tout cas sur cette
question du droit à l'erreur de savoir
ce que vous aviez peut-être comme
préconisations pour faire en sorte que
justement on puisse revenir en arrière
et pouvoir réparer les situations qui
sont qui sont complexes ensuite vous
appuyez beaucoup sur le fait que on a un
système une plateforme qui est numérique
bon on retrouve partout la problématique
de l'accès aux services publics et à la
fois de la question de la précarité
numérique et de toutes les personnes
qu'on ne touche pas à travers ça et donc
la nécessité de d'accompagnateur
avec du coup mon accompagnateur rénov
est-ce que ça vous semble un
intermédiaire en tout cas quelque chose
alors c'est on va dire tout récent mais
qui pourrait jouer aussi ce rôle là quoi
c'est à dire ce cet accompagnateur Renov
donc on imagine qu'il sera qu'il est
déjà mais qui qui va se multiplier sur
l'ensemble des territoires et qui puisse
justement cette interlocuteur qui permet
soit d'accompagner vers une plateforme
soit justement d'avoir un contact
physique direct mais en tout cas voilà
est-ce que dans le l'orientation de cet
accompagnateur rénov et de ce qu'on peut
en voir quel est votre votre avis par
rapport à par rapport à ça et puis
j'avais aussi une question sur pour
avoir fait un petit peu l'expérience
savoir si vous aviez eu des retours sur
cet aspect là c'est vrai que sur la
plateforme de France rénov de Lana en
fait quand on commence à rentrer
l'ensemble des données
moi j'ai déjà fait le le constat que
quelques temps après on avait beaucoup
de sollicitations en termes de ma
chaleur etc etc donc ce qui veut dire
que du coup c'est donner là
sont diffusées et savoir si vous des
informations sur sur ces
remontées en tout cas parce que c'est
vrai que ça pose question en fait que
ces données là soient puisse être
diffusées en tout cas revendu enfin j'en
sais rien enfin en tout cas parce que
c'est vrai que c'est un autre aspect
c'est que comme du coup ces personnes
ensuite sont contactées par différents
opérateurs souvent pas forcément de
bonne foi du coup réorienter se faire
d'autres vers d'autres canaux quelqu'un
qui veut faire ça c'est une rénovation
plutôt globale etc qui va être contacté
par quelqu'un qui va lui vendre une
pompe à chaleur enfin voilà en tout cas
je pense que ça c'est une vraie réalité
je l'ai essayé en vrai j'ai et il m'a
pas fallu je pense aller une
demi-journée pour recevoir beaucoup
d'appels derrière donc c'est quelque
chose qui qui existe et puis pour
terminer savoir si dans les
sollicitations que vous avez eues et les
différents problématiques est-ce que
vous avez fait une analyse on va dire
territoriale quoi est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui j'ai pas plutôt rural
plutôt urbain est-ce que contraire il y
a pas tellement de différence
et notamment sur cet accès justement
généralement au service public mais
est-ce qu'on a un peu une carte de ces
problématiques là merci
merci beaucoup pour vos questions sur la
question du droit à l'erreur dans les
erreurs qu'on a pu observer c'est des
erreurs sur le numéro fiscal c'est des
erreurs sur avoir mal coché monsieur ou
madame donc des
erreurs qui en plus que tout le monde
peut faire alors là pour le coup je
pense vraiment qu'il faut arrêter de
penser que c'est que les plus en
difficulté avec le numérique et c'est
vraiment parce que ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure le pas pouvoir corriger
ces erreurs comme on le fait pour les
impôts ce qui prouve que c'est faisable
mais on le préconise aussi sur certaines
aides sociales enfin de la même manière
il faut pouvoir corriger quand on a fait
une erreur et puis je on voit bien la
crainte de la fraude qui est qui est
c'est normal de lutter contre l'afrod
mais on voit bien comment la lutte
contre la fraude peut empêcher d'accéder
au droit parce que là on est vraiment
dans cette situation là c'est à cause de
la peur de la fraude qu'un certain
nombre de cas ne sont pas réglés et donc
je trouve que c'est intéressant de
montrer la balance qui peut y avoir et
évidemment qu'il faut lutter contre la
fraude mais attention à ce que ça
n'empêche pas d'accéder à ses droits sur
les accompagnateurs ma prime rénove on
n'a pas de retour pour l'instant ça
faisait partie de nos de nos
préconisations
toute la question c'est est-ce que ces
accompagnateurs ont vraiment accès au
dossiers ce qui se passe dans les
espaces françaises qui est vraiment je
continue à dire qui est un plus pour
accéder au service public mais ce ne
sont pas des agents des des différents
services publics c'est pas des agents de
la CAF à l'intérieur c'est pas des
agents de la CPAM c'est pas des agents
de Pôle Emploi donc il y a toute une
partie des dossiers qui ne peuvent pas
régler et là il faut que la personne qui
soit la compagnateur puisse accéder au
dossier et résoudre les problèmes
autrement l'intermédiaire ne sera pas ne
sera pas suffisant sur la divulgation de
de donner on n'a pas de retour on n'a
pas d'infos on n'a pas d'infos pour
l'instant mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
ce qu'on peut observer sur l'ensemble
des demandes d'aides qui peuvent exister
quand les gens sont pas à l'aise avec le
numérique c'est qu'on leur crée une
boîte mail
la personne qui crée la boîte mail qui
peut aussi bien d'ailleurs est une
assistante sociale ou autre à le code
peut garder le code ou pas le garder
mais la personne aussi en question
oublie son code c'est que c'est quand
même quelque chose de d'excessivement
d'excessivement fréquent je pourrais
vous donner une anecdote quand j'étais
aux Antilles mais qui à mon avis n'est
pas une anecdote sur une une déléguée
qui me dit dans nos délégués
territoriaux qui me dit bah j'ai eu un
vieux monsieur en face de moi à qui je
dis mais attends il faut que vous me
disiez c'est quoi quel est votre boîte
mail il me dit mais c'est quoi ma boîte
mail voilà donc n'ayant absolument hors
on lui avait créé une boîte mail donc ça
c'est quand même la la réalité et sur la
question de l'analyse territoriale non
on n'est pas en capacité de vous dire
s'il y a des régions où il y en a plus
ou pas par contre c'est plutôt des
situations de personnes âgées de
personnes vulnérables de difficultés
d'accès un modeste et comme la prime
rénov elle a été fait pour les gens
modestes voilà c'est c'est peut-être
vous dire un mot du coup là-dessus sur
nos vous savez comment en fait on
fonctionne des juristes au siège
250 personnes majoritairement des
juristes de à mes côtés donc au début ma
prime rénov va complètement être traitée
au siège
par le pôle dans lequel que dirige mode
mais après là maintenant c'est reparti
sur nos délégués une fois qu'on a donné
un certain nombre de préconisations
disent qu'il fallait faire porte
d'entrée à Lana maintenant c'est traité
par nos délégués c'est très intéressant
parce que je 570 délégués sur le
territoire qui sont des bénévoles qui
ont une indemnité quand même de 400
euros par mois qui ont gros s'engage à
faire deux demi-journées de permanence
par semaine et deux demi-journée pour
régler les dossiers la réalité
honnêtement c'est qu'ils travaillent
plutôt 3 ou 4 jours par semaine quand
c'est pas quand c'est pas un peu plus
j'ai fait plusieurs collégiales là c'est
15 derniers jours j'ai rencontré de nos
délégués les collégiales c'est quand on
réunit les délégués justement sur des
partages de bonnes pratiques des
difficultés je les ai rencontrés là
récemment à Bourges à Rennes et à Toulon
tous bon alertés sur ma prime rénove ça
a été le on démarre tout de suite bon
qu'elles sont en gros les difficultés
que vous rencontrez ils ont démarré par
sur un homme et surtout par c'est
insupportable Anna de nous répond pas
donc je voulais vous faire remonter ça
parce qu'en fait nos délégués ils sont
bénévoles et ils trouvent un grand
plaisir à régler les problèmes je dirais
que leur paiement est du fait de la
satisfaction de réussir à résoudre des
problèmes quand ils ont pas de réponse
des services publics et qui n'arrivent
pas à résoudre les problèmes leur
travail perd complètement et là c'était
dans les trois endroits la première
chose qui m'ont dit on a on n'a pas de
réponse les dossiers alors évidemment
quand j'en reparle ici ils me disent bah
oui les dossiers de temps en temps ça
met plusieurs mois mais nos délégués
quand au bout d'un mois il y a pas de
réponse que le réclamant revient en
disant mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé et
ils ont en face d'eux des gens en
difficulté et c'est lourd à porter comme
comme question donc voilà je voulais
vous dire que ce qui me frappe là en ce
moment c'est que les délégués et et la
secrétaire général avec le délégué
général la médiation c'est en ce moment
à Marseille et c'est aussi la première
chose qui a été sortie dans la
collégiale donc je voulais vous vous
alerter là-dessus j'ai répondu à vos
questions alors
oui
merci madame la Présidente ce rapporteur
madame la défenseur merci pour votre
propos liminaire j'ai bien retenu ce que
vous venez dire concernant la fraude qui
ne doit pas être un frein au recours au
droit et au bon droit et puis la
difficulté par rapport à bon nombre de
nos concitoyens au regard des procédures
qui sont uniquement dématérialisées pour
ce faire les maisons France services ont
dans leur
ADN normalement
la possibilité de remédier à ça auprès
des requérants il se trouve que vous
venez de mentionner un point sur une
difficulté qui est réelle qu'on constate
dans nos territoires y compris lors de
nos permanences c'est que les agents qui
sont en charge de ces maisons France
services n'ont pas accès aux données des
différentes administrations pour
lesquelles ils doivent normalement être
le point d'entrée et donner satisfaction
à l'usager or il me semble que
mais je voudrais juste avoir votre avis
il y a une difficulté réelle et le
rapporteur vient differ allusion dans la
transmission d'un certain nombre de
données et des sollicitations à
caractère commercial qui s'ensuivent
il nous faut aussi être Protecteur du
citoyen dans l'aspect des données qu'il
est susceptible de mettre à disposition
d'une administration quelle qu'elle soit
cependant ne pensez-vous pas que il
puisse y avoir là aussi un système
d'accréditation jusqu'à un certain
niveau d'information pour chacune des
administrations pense que ça pourrait
être me semble-t-il une voix
d'amélioration du service rendu par les
maisons françaises et pour se faire il
faudrait sans doute interroger chacune
des administrations présente au sein des
maisons France service et définir de
manière collégiale un niveau
d'accréditation
suffisant pour permettre d'avancer tout
au moins de faire avancer la question du
requérant et d'apporter un début de
réponse je voudrais avoir votre
sentiment là-dessus d'abord je suis
assez convaincu que vous voyez dans vos
permanences les mêmes choses que ce
qu'on peut observer dans nos
réclamations je les constaté plusieurs
fois et ça c'est c'est sûr que vous
voyez à peu près les mêmes genres de
difficultés que ce qu'on peut observer
sur cette question des accréditations et
des espaces en service et vous savez que
notre préconisation de départ sur la
dématérialisation c'était dans la
création de ces espaces françaises que
ce soit des agents directement de la
cave de la CPAM est-ce que nous pouvons
nous avons une centaine de nos délégués
qui sont présents dans les espaces
France services alors pareil on sera
jamais en capacité d'évaluer l'ensemble
des espaces en service mais on peut voir
les endroits où ça fonctionne ou pas et
pourquoi là dessus j'ai jamais
d'accusation contre les agents qui sont
dans ces espaces françaises ni dans ses
sal qui honnêtement cherche à faire au
mieux en gros si par exemple je vous
prends l'exemple de la CAF si l'endroit
le territoire la CAF est en difficulté
parce qu'elle a du mal de toutes les
manières à traiter tous les dossiers
elle a aussi du mal à répondre à
l'espace français service si elle-même
n'est pas en difficulté et qui a un
canal assez facile ça fonctionne l'agent
espace françaisvice appelle la CAF et
arrive à régler le problème mais il y a
plein de moments où les agents des
espaces en service nous ont dit mais moi
je peux passer une heure à appeler la
CAF ou la CPAM et à ne pas avoir de
réponse mais parce que même sans
difficulté de l'autre côté mais je
n'accuse pas donc oui moi je pense que
la question de l'accès au dossier enfin
et du coup de ce que vous dites une
forme d'accréditation pour pouvoir
résoudre les problèmes me paraîtrait à
mon avis importante en tout cas il faut
aller plus loin que que ce qui est juste
juste fait pour l'instant je vous ferai
une petite parenthèse sur la question de
la formation dans les espaces françaises
nos délégués dit certains agents dans
les espaces françaises sont formés une
journée ou une journée et demi nos
délégués quand ils démarrent ils sont
formés une semaine complète et je peux
vous dire qu'il ressortent en disant
vous nous remplissez bien bien la tête
et surtout on fait de la formation
continue derrière c'est à dire que
vraiment dès qu'il y a des nouveautés
des cas voilà et les collégiales sont un
moyen aussi de de continuer de continuer
à former
autre chose aussi que je voulais que je
voulais vous rajouter c'est quand même
sur le nombre de personnes en difficulté
avec le numérique je sais pas si vous
avez entendu parler de la dernière du
dernier rapport de la NCT qui n'est pas
encore rendu public mais dans quelques
chiffres sont sortis et sur les éloignés
du numérique auquel ils agrègent ceux
qui sont en difficulté avec le numérique
ceux qui n'ont pas accès à Internet on
est à plus de 16 millions de personnes
on sait on est à 31,5% de la population
française donc on est quasi à un tiers
il faut juste faire avec cette réalité
qui est une réalité et donc je continue
à dire ce n'est pas possible de demander
et de d'imposer des large dématérialisée
dans ce contexte avec un tiers de la
population qui qui est en difficulté et
je trouve que du coup le problème en
fait c'est pas la dématérialisation
enfin moi je continue à dire que c'est
une chance pour plein de personnes ça
peut simplifier les démarches encore que
chacun de nous peut un faire des erreurs
de être confronté à des bugs mais mais
c'est pas la dématérialisation c'est
d'avoir supprimé les accueils physiques
et téléphoniques le problème et de ne
pas avoir la possibilité de déposer un
dossier papier la décision du Conseil
d'État du mois de juin et qui est très
clair là-dessus qui dit le problème
c'est pas tant la dématérialisation
c'est que tant que les gens sont pas en
capacité il faut qu'il soit soit
accompagnés c'est pour les préfectures
la décision soit accompagné soit qu'il
puisse déposer un dossier papier la
décision n'est pas encore franchement
complètement appliquée dans les
préfectures
alors est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
questions de la part de nos collègues
est-ce que vous avez
depuis que vous êtes saisis de ce
dossier de ma prime rénove eu des
échanges directs avec la directrice
générale de Lada avec son président
comment voilà comment les choses se
passent entre entre vous et voilà est-ce
qu'il y a de part et d'autre une volonté
de de se dire que voilà c'est un enjeu
que tout le monde peut partager un défi
à relever et comment vous comment sont
vos relations avec les deux têtes de de
la nacre sur la directrice générale et
le président quoi
oui heureusement et enfin si nous on
veut résoudre les problèmes il faut des
liens et des liens en bonne intelligence
donc effectivement j'ai rencontré la
directrice les équipes ont rencontré le
secrétaire général donc il y a des
échanges avec je viens de réécrire à la
directrice pour lui dire toutes les
obstacles que nous continuons à observer
et les non-réponses auxquelles nous
sommes confrontés ou ce que je vous
disais c'est à dire le l'usager a eu une
réponse mais ça n'a pas débloqué pour
autant son dossier et ça c'est aussi ce
qu'on voit ce qu'on voit apparaître je
enfin j'entends bien la phrase qui est
dit et par Lana et par le ministre
d'ailleurs aussi mais finalement c'est
très peu le nombre de par rapport à tout
ce qu'on arrive à régler oui c'est c'est
évidemment mais d'abord c'est pas si peu
que ça moi je suis pas d'accord quand
bien même des personnes n'arriveront pas
à accéder à leurs droits on sera
toujours là pour essayer les défunts et
puis en fait je voudrais vous dire si
c'est si peu je comprends pas pourquoi
c'est pas réglé voilà moi c'est
d'ailleurs j'ai un autre raisonnement
c'est que si effectivement voilà et ce
qu'on constate c'est que c'est pas réglé
donc moi j'ai plutôt tendance à penser
que nous ne sommes pas suffisamment
connus et que donc il y a plein de gens
qui ne nous saisissent pas et je
voudrais vous redire à quel point c'est
délétère pour les personnes d'observer
que leur voisin a réussi à obtenir
l'aide et pas eux et qu'il y a pas
d'explication pourquoi et ça en terme de
cohésion sociale je vous assure que
c'est vous le voyez aussi c'est
complètement délété donc je pense que je
trouve qu'il ne faut pas minimiser le
nombre et et le nombre est probablement
beaucoup plus important
tout à fait ce que ce que vous dites
mais pour quel que soit la réclamation
moi j'ai pas mon été plus de 10 ans
président de l'office public de
l'habitat je disais à mes services c'est
dramatique quand il n'y a pas de réponse
quand les gens ne savent pas c'est leur
demande a été prise en compte si elle
est actuellement étudié si voilà le
principal c'est de pouvoir les tenir
informés parce que par ce biais là déjà
on arrive à faire tomber un certain
nombre d'irrationnel et on arrive mieux
ensuite à pouvoir expliquer pourquoi ça
n'a pas abouti pourquoi il y a eu des
difficultés mais je suis complètement
d'accord
en fait la question pour nous et c'est
ce que demande nos délégués c'est
quelqu'un à qui parler qui peut régler
le dossier pour aller dans votre sens
sur les explications je voudrais vous
raconter ce qu'on a fait au moment vous
savez on a fait partie de
l'expérimentation sur la MPO la
médiation préalable obligatoire dans
certains départements sur RSA et les
aides et les aides au logement et quand
on a évalué cette expérimentation on a
évidemment pas voulu demander aux
personnes concernées qu'est-ce qu'elles
en ont pensé je me permets une petite
parenthèse pour l'emploi qui a fait
partie aussi l'expérimentation n'est pas
la demander aux usagers ce qu'ils en ont
pensé je pense que quand on évalue une
politique publique demandez aux usagers
me paraît absolument la base ce qui
était très intéressant quand on a
demandé au
usagers qui eux ont pensé de notre
médiation préalable obligatoire c'est
qu'évidemment nous on se doutait à
priori qui avait un tiers des personnes
qui avaient obtenu satisfaction qui
allait dire qu'ils allaient être content
et les deux tiers pas content pas du
tout il y a eu deux tiers de satisfait
parce que il y a eu le tiers qui a
obtenu
réparation et l'aide auquel il avait
droit et l'entretien on lui a juste
expliqué pourquoi il n'y avait pas droit
et ils ont dit mais moi je suis très
content j'ai compris pourquoi j'y avais
pas droit et donc ça et donc ça ça dit
le travail qu'il faut faire
d'explication nous on est en train aussi
de se le mettre en place c'est-à-dire
moi je trouve de temps en temps qu'on
peut envoyer des courriers à nos
réclamants que je me dis mais je ne suis
pas sûr qu'ils comprennent absolument
tout on a entrepris un travail de
plusieurs mois de clarification de nos
courriers des éléments que l'on peut
envoyer de ce qui est sur notre site
internet qu'on est en train on fait tout
un travail de clarification et je pense
que vraiment les services publics
doivent parce que on a eu par exemple un
Rica réclamment et ça c'était très
intéressant et la CAF est
notre délégué comprenait pas pourquoi il
était pas content il avait une remise de
dette il était pas content il était pas
content de la remise de l'être et en
fait il comprenait pas la remise de
dette et il suffisait de lui mettre pour
mettre le terme juridique remise qu'on
lui explique ça veut dire que vous
n'avez plus de dettes voilà que vous ne
devez plus rien c'est juste mais je
trouve que c'est hyper intéressant parce
que oui en fait si on y réfléchit qu'on
connaît pas ce terme-là remise de dette
vous pouvez dire remis enfin voilà donc
je pense que l'explication est vitale
non c'est une question complémentaire
par rapport à je sais pas si en fait du
coup tant que défenseur des droits vous
aviez déjà fait
des études où c'est des retours entre la
partie cite donc crédit d'impôt et le
passage à ma prime rénov quoi est-ce que
vous avez vu différence des évolutions
par rapport en fait à ces deux
dispositifs qui ont été assez différents
je suis pas tout à fait en capacité de
vous répondre mais mais par contre ce
que je voudrais sur les recours contre
des décisions de Lana quand les
particuliers on n'ont pas pu bénéficier
de la prime rénov et font un recours
dans le recours pareil il y a pas
d'explication du pourquoi et c'est aussi
pour ça que de temps en temps les
personnes se retournent vers nous c'est
parce qu'elle cherche à avoir une
explication du pourquoi pourquoi il y a
eu pourquoi il y a eu un rejet non de
façon plus générale en fait
sur ces questions de rénovation enfin de
rénovation énergétique il va y en avoir
de plus en plus d'être il y a des
besoins d'aide donc on va en créer de
plus en plus et je trouve que ce qu'on
observe là doit nous servir sur ce qu'il
faut faire à ne pas faire sur la suite
voilà et je pense enfin je redis la
question de l'accueil physique est
absolument indispensable et d'une
cellule en capacité de gérer les bugs
informatiques nous observons exactement
la même chose sur les APL et le
versement direct des aides il y a des
bugs et il y a personne à contacter
quand il y a et je vous alerte là-dessus
parce que si on fait la même chose sur
le RSA avec des aides
automatiques quand il y a des bugs les
personnes vont se retrouver sans rien et
avec personne à qui demander et et avec
l'informatique il y aura toujours des
bugs voilà
et puis par rapport aux différentes
auditions j'espère que que les choses
s'amélioreront parce que effectivement
on regarde des des enjeux importants qui
donc doivent être mises en oeuvre pour
atteindre le plus de rénovation globale
et performante et surtout relever ces
enjeux voilà il reste à souhaiter que
effectivement alors peut-être qu'il y a
aussi des difficultés par rapport au
fait qu'aujourd'hui vous disiez il y a
beaucoup d'aide cette forêt d'aide aussi
malheureusement elle ne facilite pas la
compréhension de la part des usagers les
aides qui sont versées par l'anal les
êtres qui peuvent être complétés à
bondés par des collectivités enfin tout
ça c'est extrêmement complexe donc c'est
aussi ce qu'on va peut-être essayer de
proposer en termes de recommandations on
le sait bien il y a une question aussi
de de lisibilité de visibilité de
simplification tout simplement et ça ça
peut être aussi des conséquences et
répercussions sur ce que vous avez
constaté vous directement et c'est quand
même pour répondre à votre question
maintenant
la question des étapes de la procédure
sur la prime rénove qui n'y avait pas
sur le sur le crédit d'impôt qui était
qui était postérieur et qui du coup
simplifié les choses puisqu'on a eu
enfin l'histoire que je vous ai raconté
au début sur la femme qui est quand même
et confronté au fait qu'il faut qu'elle
fasse les travaux autrement les 100
chauffage ils sont eau chaude parce que
du coup elle a pas respecté la procédure
je pense que ça aussi est une est une
difficulté
merci beaucoup merci Madame et messieurs
dames merci on vous souhaite une bonne
journée merci